ich wüsste nicht vorüber aber ich du
wurdest zwei mal betrogen
von jonas und von deiner mutter von mir
irgendwie auch weil ich selber betrogen
wurde
ich will ja muss sagen das ist nicht
sehr traurig macht
nicht nur weil du mir leid tut sondern
auch weil ich dich als freundin verloren
habe hätte ich gewusst dass du mit jojo
zusammen bis dann hätte ich niemals was
mit ihm angefangen das musst du mir
glauben ich weiß doch auch nicht warum
er das getan hat weil er sich in dich
verliebt hat aber das macht es doch auch
nicht anders oder der grund warum dich
deine mutter belogen hat ach du weißt
warum sie das getan hat weil sie einfach
wahnsinnige angst hatte ich zu verlieren
keine mutter ist es einfach die eigene
tochter gehen zu lassen
ja und bin noch erwachsen
du wirst aber immer ihre tochter sein
guck mal du bist ausgezogen du studierst
du bist oder war es mit diesem musiker
zusammen und sie bleibt ganz allein
zurück aber deswegen kann man doch nicht
so eine show abziehen
das ist doch krank
du und ich wir wissen doch ganz genau
dass man manchmal aus liebe richtig
dumme sachen du und deine mutter ihr
müsst euch vielleicht mal richtig
aussprechen
und wer hat da man entwirft ich nicht
will kann es denn gewesen sein
vielleicht mag ich weiß es doch auch
nicht mal dreht zurzeit total durch
meinst du
hat mir auch das foto von giraud
zugesteckt es gibt ein foto von jona und
mir ja lag unter meiner bettdecke
vielleicht sollten wir einfach heute
abend mal mit marc reden
ich muss jetzt erst mal mit meiner
mutter sprechen